♪ ♪ ♪t les premiers mètres
d'une fosse minière qui
s'étendra sur 2,5 km. Un lieu
François Legault, qui rêvent de
Québec la batterie du
nord-est américain. Nous sommes
165 km au nord de Montréal.JULI,
Nouveau Monde Graphite
du gisement Matawinie.
Tu vois, tout ce qui scintille,
en réalité, ce sont
Donc, ici, on le voit bien.
On a du On a du On a du On a du.
- Le graphite est un minerail dn
des batteries électriques
pour véhicules. L'entreprise
Nouveau Monde Graphiteespère qua
en opération en 20
- Ici, on a un gisement gagnant.
minéralogie. Pour nous, d'avoir
accès au réseau électrique,
d'avoir accès aux routes,
d'entrepreneurs locaux,
un bassin de travailleurs...
- Le sud-ouest du Québec, dont
d'avenir comme le graphite et le
lithium, est plus convoité que
jamais par l'industrie minière.
des "claims" miniers, c'est-à-
dire les titres d'exploration,
souvent en terre publique, qu'ur
un territoire. Ici, on voit en
rouge les secteurs qui étaient
couverts par des "claims"minieùl
y en a aujourd'hui, en 2022.
Le rouge a éclaboussé le sud-
ouest du Québec. L'augmentation
du nombre de "claims" y a été
cinq fois plus rapide
qu'ailleurs dans la province.
LOUIS ST-HILAIRE, Protection
des Lacs de la Petite Nation
- C'est quelque chose
de préoccupant pour chacun
des citoyens, et les citoyens
ne sont pas au courant de ça.
Ils n'ont aucune information
qu'il peut y avoir derrière
chez eux quelques kilomètres
de "claim".
- C'est l'organisme
de Louis St-Hilaire qui aréaliss
en épluchant les données
du gouvernement du Québec.
- Il y a des claims qu'on a
découverts, que pe
ne connaissait, qui sont
du côté du mont Tremblant.
C'est des claims qui sont
aussi grands que le parc
du Mont-Tremblant lui-même.
C'était pas là,
la dernière fois.
UGO LAPOINTE, Coalition Pour que
le Québec ait meilleure mine
- Je m'attendais peut-être
à une augmentation quelconque,
mais pas de cette ampleur-là.Ça,
en "claims" miniers,
depuis 18 mois. Dans certaines
régions, comme Lanaudière,ça a .
- Le projet de Nouveau Monde
Graphite a peut-être suscité
des convoitises dans Lanaudière.
Avant ces travaux qui ont débuté
sur le terrain de la future
usine, tout a commencé par
un claim minier.
- À priori, c'est pas
extrêmement envahissant.
Puis initialement, c'est
un géologue avec sa pelle qui se
présente sur le site puis qui
s'en va vérifier ce que ça a
l'air. De fil en aiguille,
si les tests sont concluants,
bien, là, on fait une tranchée,
on va un peu plus loin, on fait
un peu de forage.
- Comme au Québec,
le sous-sol n'appartient pas
aux propriétaires des terrains,
le processus d'un
aboutir à des expropriations
lorsqu'un projet a le feu vert
des Autorités. Nouveau Monde
Graphite n'a exproprié personne,
mais a acheté 25 terrains et
neuf maisons à des voisins.
Parmi tous ces nombreux claims
miniers, combien mèneront
réellement à un projet concret
comme ici à St-Michel-des-
Saints?
C'est la grande question.
VALÉRIE FILLION, dg Asso de
l'explo minière du Québec
- Je suis bien embêtée de
vous dire combien il pourraitav,
de graphite. Il y en a quelques
unes qui avancent plus.
- Il ne faut pas se laisserimpre
claims dans le sud-ouest du
Québec, dit l'Association de
l'exploration minière du Québec.
- Il y as, il y a s, il y a s, s
claims miniers en vigueur dans
cette région-là, mais
il n'y a pas d'espace pour
faire d'expansion tant que ça,
parce qu'il y a tellement
d'interdictions partout tout
autour que c'est vraiment
un enjeu.
- Au cabinet du Ministre de
l'Énergie et des Ressources
naturelles,
on répond qu'il est :
- C'est la fierté du Québec de
dire : On a des ressources puis
on les développe de manière
responsable. Je comprends qu'à
certains égards, il y a
une approche de : "pas dans
ma cour". Puis dans notre cas,
on a été capables de contrôler
tous les impacts à l'intérieur
d'un km du site minier
- Les choix sont cruciaux pour
le développement du Québec et
les élus municipaux veulent être
consultés davantage.
Avez-vous des claims sur votre
territoire?
ISABELLE PERREAULT, mairesse et
préfète de la MRC de Matawini
- Oui, on en a quelques uns,
très peu. La loi sur les mines
est au-dessus de toutes
les autres lois! Donc,
le sous-sol de notre territoire
ne fait pas partie de nos
pouvoirs d'aménagement du
territoire. Donc, ce que ça veut
dire, c'est qu'on n'a pas de
contrôle, on n'a pas
d'informations.
MARC L'HEUREUX, maire de Brébeuf
et préfet MRC des Laurentides
- On n'e
le fond, l'activité minière.
Mais le problème est qu'il
faudrait qu'elle se fasse en
dehors des zones, au moins,
de protéger les lacs.
- Des MRC, comme celle
Laurentides, ont fait des
propositions à Québec,
s.
- Et là, on doit déterminer
les zones qui sont incompatibles
avec l'activité minière.
Mais on ne s'entend pas avecrnes
orientations qui sont
différentes. Nous autres,
on a présenté des exclusions,
mais c'est trop grand ce qu'on .
- En Outaouais depuis quelques
semaines, une vingtaine de
municipalités s'affichent même
ouvertement contre les mines.- e
un moratoire maintenant, de
prendre le temps de regarder
la situation, de changer
les balises pour s'assurer que
les milieux touristiques soient
protégés et s'assurer que
les milieux écologiques
sensibles soient protégés.
- Si on attend puis on ne va
voir qu'est-ce qu'il y a en
dessous de nos pieds au Québec,
ça va finir qu'on va importer
la substance premi
♪ ♪ ♪
- En pleine course économique
mondiale pour électrifier
les transports, le Québec a donc
un dilemme à résoudre.
Le sujet pourrait bien rebondir.
Ici Jean-Sébastien Cloutier,
Radio-C